live aus köln der presseclub mit jörg
schönenborn
herzlich willkommen schön dass sie dabei
sind an diesem sonntagmittag sie haben
es in der tagesschau fahrzeug das ist
stürmisch in europa dass das
meteorologische angeht wird es sich
morgen abend beruhigt haben dann ist die
atmosphäre wieder normal politisch gilt
das leider nicht im gegenteil die lage
eskaliert weiter geheimdienste
beobachten dass die prorussischen
rebellen in der ost ukraine immer
häufiger provozieren offenbar versuchen
sie vor wende zu schaffen für einen
russischen angriff und im kreml setzt
präsident putin persönlich nadelstiche
gestern dirigierte er zusammen mit dem
belarussischen diktator lukaschenko
raketen manöver kurz als diese woche so
aus als würde sich die lage beruhigen
als kanzler scholz in moskau war das
russische fernsehen hatte bilder von
truppen abzügen veröffentlicht aber das
war offenbar nur ein täuschungsmanöver
jetzt am wochenende sind sich der
amerikanische präsident der
nato-generalsekretär und viele andere
politikerinnen und politiker einig ein
einmarsch der russischen truppen in die
ukraine scheint unmittelbar
bevorzustehen unser thema heute russland
und ukraine offener krieg oder kalter
friede und ich freue mich sehr auf diese
kompetente runde eric kirschbaum ist bei
uns erlebt als freier journalist in
berlin schreibt unter anderem für die
los angeles times ich freue mich dass
gera post bei uns ist autor und freier
journalist früher leitete europa
redaktion der deutschen welle herzlich
willkommen ich begrüße helga schmidt vom
westdeutschen rundfunk sie leitet das
hörfunkstudio von wdr und ndr in brüssel
und paul anton krüger korrespondent der
süddeutschen zeitung in berlin ist bei
uns herr krüger sie kommen direkt von
der münchner sicherheitskonferenz dort
wurde der eindruck stark vermittelt dass
der einmarsch unmittelbar bevorsteht ist
das auch ihr eindruck
zumindest ist alles dafür vor ort was
russland brauchen würde um eine größere
militäraktion gegen die ukraine zustand
und bundeskanzler scholz hat noch mal
vor der hybris gewarnt irgendwie dass
man jetzt sozusagen sich in den kopf von
putin hineinversetzen könne wer
letztlich die entscheidung dazu fällen
würde ich glaube daran knüpft sich die
hoffnung dass man noch einfluss nehmen
kann es wird heute weitere telefonate
geben präsident marco will mit putin
sprechen möglicherweise gibt es auch
noch überlegungen das beiden und putin
noch mal sprechen den versuch das auf
eine sehr hohe ebene zu eskalieren um
nochmal eine chance zu finden das
abzuwenden aber von dem militärischen
fähigkeiten die russland jetzt an drei
flanken um die ukraine versammelt hat
muss man leider befürchten dass es
jederzeit losgehen könnte verschmiert
sie arbeiten in brüssel da sitzt nicht
nur die eu sondern auch die nato wie es
ihrer einschätzung hat die diplomatie
noch eine chance bei der nato sagt man
ja schon seit einigen tagen das im
grunde alle vorbereitungen getroffen
sind das ist ein einmarsch geben kann
gleichzeitig hat auch der
nato-generalsekretär jens stoltenberg
immer darauf verwiesen dass die
verhandlungen weitergeführt werden
können jetzt gab es aber in dieser woche
ein ich würde sagen enttäuschen das
antwortschreiben des russischen
präsidenten putin
der auf die antwort des westens der nato
geschrieben hat also er werde nicht über
einzelne vorschläge verhandeln das war
ja ein bisschen die hoffnung des westens
man könnte über abrüstung über
rüstungskontrolle wieder ins gespräch
kommen er hat jetzt geschrieben dazu sei
er nicht bereit also das ganze paket
sieht aus seiner sicht so aus dass über
die
über die verpflichtung der nato die er
sich wünscht auf die ost erweiterung auf
eine weitere ost-erweiterung zufällig
den gesprächen gesprochen werden muss
und das ist natürlich für die nato ein
heißes eisen da wenn man nicht ranken
der amerikanische präsident sagt putin
habe sich nach seiner überzeugung schon
entschieden dass da gar nicht mehr
rückgängig zu machen
ja beiden nun die märkische geheimdienst
haben viele informationen jetzt in
öffentlichkeit gegeben ob alles stimmt
wissen wir nicht aber die wurde und
damit vielleicht den krieg verhindern
2014 haben die information gehabt vor
spinnen haben das nicht veröffentlich
haben deswegen die wohnen den fehler
verhindern hoffentlich hat wird es eine
wirkung haben die männer glaubt dass der
krieg bevorsteht wir wissen aber wie
viele soldaten 200.000 fast um krim
herum ich hoffe dass es noch ein plus
ich hoffe dass puten irgendwie denkt er
kann kriegen was er will ohne das
erschießen muss keine ahnung vielleicht
bin ich eine kleine minderheit aber wer
weiß dass putin vor hat das ist die
spannende frage und wenn joe biden sagte
glaubt das putten demnächst
einmarschiert dann weiß ich dass ich
treffe das ganze nur ein blatt oder
wirklich in die letzte phase der
vorbereitung
möglicherweise ein bluff der amerikaner
aber
unterstützt von den russen indirekt also
wie in schach spielen genommen man
interessiert sich nicht für den nächsten
zug sondern für den übernächsten oder
die nächsten züge was wird der andere
tun und vielleicht erhofft sich
die hoffen sich die amerikaner dadurch
dass durch ihre
ankündigung
die russen doch ein rückzieher machen
vorläufig damit und die russen sagen
guck mal hier was die alles erzählen
dass tritt doch nicht ein wer ist der
lügner dann auch welcher seite im moment
und das ist ich weiß nicht ob das spiel
richtig ist aber es ist auch im moment
ein diplomatisches spiel zwischen
russland und amerika wobei wir in europa
in dazwischen sind und gar nicht wissen
wer überhaupt recht hat ist ganz
interessant also danke an alle die uns
in den sozialen netzwerken wieder
verfolgen bei presseclub und tagesschau
danke für ihren für viele für den
rückmeldungen die ich im studio auch
verfolgen kann
das spielt das eine große rolle also
dass der kreml verunsichert mit
unterschiedlichen botschaften das ist
offenkundig so widersprüchlich wie sie
sind aber es überrascht doch einige dass
die amerikanische regierung immer wieder
konkrete angriffszeit punkte ankündigt
und das ganze als quasi sicher und
bevorstehend darstellt jetzt sagen sie
beide das könnte auch teil eines spiels
und auch im spiel sein das ist kein
spiel ich meine die märkte wo kein krieg
wurde das wort reden verhandeln hier sie
wollen damit verhindern dass ist im
krieg kommt und dann vielleicht klappt
das vielleicht nicht in was puten markt
mit den zutaten an der grenze direkt nur
ein spiel von puten keine ahnung aber es
ist wichtig zu betonen die amerikaner
wollen hier wirklich kein krieg wie die
europäer nicht was tun wir das sind wir
noch nicht aber
wichtiger ist dass die amerikaner wohl
kein krieg und mit dieser öffentlichkeit
ist ungewöhnlich das gab es vorher noch
nicht so viel geheimdienstinformationen
aber ich habe ziemlich viel vertrauen in
die amerikanische geheimdienste ich
glaube die wissen vielmehr soll jeder
wissen werden und bin ich so offen damit
umgehen dann kann man hinhören aber
sonst haben sie heute kann man auch gut
verstehen
man will ja nicht der tatenlos zusehen
wie 2014 krimmer sozusagen unter dem
radar der öffentlichen wahrnehmung
erobert werden konnte ja aber ich finde
der amerikanische präsident unterschätzt
welche folgen das haben kann für die
glaubwürdigkeit wir haben schon einen
termin verstreichen sehen aus russland
wurde dann gesagt also an einem mittwoch
wurde noch nie ein krieg in europa
begonnen also zynisch gleichzeitig auf
der anderen seite erleben wir doch auch
dass die menschen sehr verunsichert sind
gerade die menschen die dem westen
vertrauen die für die das wort eines
amerikanischen präsidenten gewicht hat
und ich glaube das darf man nicht
unterschätzen also wenn jetzt noch ein
zwei mal so ein termin verstreicht
beispielsweise in der nächsten woche
kann das gefährlich sein zumal putin
also selbst wenn er die absicht haben
sollte ist doch unwahrscheinlich dass er
dem amerikanischen präsidenten den
gefallen tut und dann einmarschiert wann
das vorausgesagt
die dynamik also haben versucht und das
ist ja dann letztlich auch so dass man
sich bewegen kann wenn man sagt okay in
der nächsten woche könnte ein angriff
kommen und er kommt nicht sagt der kreml
anja haben wir euch gleich gesagt wir
planen keinen angriff das was man dort
sieht auf satellitenbildern und dann
natürlich haben die geheimdienste noch
ganz andere aufklärungsmöglichkeiten
sind halt massive gefechts bereite
truppenverbände so und das jederzeit in
der lage sind dort einzumarschieren
darüber gibt es glaube ich gar keinen
dissenz in der einschätzung
die frage ist haben die amerikanischen
geheimdienste erkenntnisse wo es um die
intentionen putins geht also gibt es zum
beispiel abgefangene kommunikation die
darauf hindeutet es gibt dinge in dem
militär verbänden dort das dort zum
beispiel zusatztanks die man hier auch
sehen kann auf den bildern auf diese
panzer aufgebracht werden die da vorher
nicht waren während sie transportiert
werden das sind alles zeichen dass man
sich breit macht für einen für einen
einsatz aber es ist letztlich noch keine
schlüssige indikation über das was putin
eigentlich will ja tatsächlich hätten
die amerikaner die amerikaner sind vor
dem irak-krieg auch nicht mit gutem
beispiel voran gekommen in dem sie auch
was behauptet haben um in den krieg zu
ziehen was man noch festgestellt hat das
war eine lüge
spekuliert russland vielleicht darauf
dass die amerikaner auch dabei erwischt
werden falschmeldungen zu ihnen in die
welt zu setzen frage zweitens ist man
als beobachter klüger wenn man nicht auf
worte hört sondern sich fragen welche
interessen stecken hinter dem handeln
der beiden seiten es läuft ja in münchen
die sicherheitskonferenz
nato-generalsekretär jens stoltenberg
ist einer der prominenten sprecher
gestern gewesen und das ist eine
interpretation was in moskau gedachten
werden könnte und was daraus wird jens
stoltenberg
wenn es das ziel des kreml sagt er
weniger nato truppen an der grenze zu
haben dann bekommen sie stattdessen mehr
und wenn sie die nato spalten wollen
dann bekommen sie nur eine stärkere l 1
also kreml ziel sei es weniger nato
truppen an der grenze zu haben und das
gegenteil hatte der kreml bislang
erreicht also wie erfolgreich ist putin
mit seiner strategie und was wir da
wirklich also ich finde er hat
eigentlich das gegenteil dessen erreicht
in vielen bereichen dass stoltenberg
auch ja und darüber hinaus auch in der
eu in brüssel staunen wir ja eigentlich
die europäer inzwischen sind das war ja
bisher kaum möglich meinen der
außenpolitik mit einer stimme zu
sprechen jetzt fährt keiner aus und alle
vertrauen offenbar marco scholz diesen
führung die haben die führung übernommen
auch ungewöhnlich in der eu
normalerweise wollen die kleinen auch
immer mitreden das haben sie geschafft
zu lösen das problem indem sie polen
auch mit eingebunden haben das ist ein
erfolg denke ich der europäischen union
ein anderes ziel putin zwar ja auch die
ukraine zu isolieren und wir erleben ja
eine welle der solidarität weltweit mit
der ukraine
was wir vorher auch nicht gesehen haben
da hat auch der amerikanische präsident
gezielt darauf hingewiesen wie
gravierend die korruption in dem land
ist das politische reformen her müssen
bevor man überhaupt über einen beitritt
sprechen kann dass wir alles vor der
eskalation und nach der eskalation muss
putin sehen dass das in diesem punkt nur
ein ziel überhaupt nicht erreicht wurde
der kirschbaum teilen sie das ja ich
finde schon dass die eu nato so einig
sind und es gab kritik vor einem halben
jahr aus beiden toten in genf getroffen
hat die europäische sagen wo es in bmc
schon so und beiden und linken haben
davon vielleicht was gelernt und blinken
war in europa wie wir wissen unterwegs
seit wochen hat in jedem bestehen
regierung gesprochen und ich bin nur
beobachter aber ich finde die märkte
haben das gut gemacht dieses mal die
europäer einzubinden das ist
unvorstellbar wenn daraus schon
präsident wäre was jetzt hier los beiden
und blinken haben das sehr gut gemacht
und die sprechen aus eine stimme und
damit hat putin vielleicht nicht mit
gerechten wird immer spalten sparen und
bis jetzt sind die europäer und vor
allem deutschland als schwaches glied
oft vor der wahl was passiert wenn es so
im krieg kommt ob die deutschen mit
verloren und wirtschaftlicher
christindesign haben ob die noch dabei
bleiben wollen aber momentan ist das
bild was putin sieht von einer geeinigt
gefestigter gruppe und das ist ein
schöner botschafter für sie stimmt
dieses bild es ist ein geeinigt des
festes westliches bündnis das die
amerikaner führen mit einem
französischen präsidenten der notfalls
auch kurz vor der wahl
militärisch aktiv werden würde mit einem
deutschen bundeskanzler der klipp und
klar und eindeutig sagen dass dem kreml
droht naja also muss auch schon
unterscheiden je länger auch diese
drohung dort umso größer wird auch das
interesse in der bevölkerung es ist ja
nicht nur die politik die die gewählten
regierungen in europa die auch das wort
zu sagen haben sondern auch eben sie
sprachen von
wahlkampf in frankreich die leute dafür
interessieren sich dafür was erwartet
uns und je länger das dauert umso
intensiver ist das interesse für die
ukraine und gestern erlebte ich also
diskussionsrunde in einem französischen
sender wo einer plötzlich fragte ja sie
zeigen immer karten mit den panzern an
der grenze also in russland an der
grenze zu europa warum zeigen sie nicht
die karte von europa wo die amerikaner
stationiert sind das heißt die gefahr
dass die stimmung bei der öffentlichen
meinung gibt zugunsten von russland sein
wir haben genau die schlicht garten die
russen auch
bemängeln
aufpassen wir haben auch unsere panzer
an der grenze zu russland und vielleicht
hat putin nicht ganz unrecht was auch so
formuliert wurde von makro ein gewisses
verständnis für für russland er hat so
zurückgezogen die diese äußerung
zumindest diese formulierung aber in der
tat
hatte russland vielleicht doch bessere
karten dass ihr europäer herr krüger
wenn ich mir angucke was unsere
nutzerinnen nutzer schreiben dann gibt
es viele die fragen putin will
sicherheitsgarantien wo ist das problem
wenn er nur den abzug der nato-truppen
will ja wie fest steht die deutsche
führende regierungspartei hinter der
gegenwärtigen westlichen strategie und
wenn dann nur den abzug der nato-truppen
will das nur ist ja schon schön ich
glaube da hat sich jetzt schon noch mal
deutlich was weg na also es gab ja auch
im wahlkampf kritische stimmen auch aus
der spd was zum beispiel die nukleare
teilhabe in der nato angeht was die
steigerungen von verteidigungsausgaben
angeht als sich der bundeskanzler am
wochenende in münchen relativ klar
geäußert dass in diesem ganzen prozess
vor dem wir jetzt stehen neues
strategisches konzept der nato
strategischer kompass der eu man auch
als deutschlands ich wird eingestehen
müssen dass es dazu gehört auch die
entsprechenden fähigkeiten
bereitzustellen also da ist glaube ich
schon eine große geschlossenheit da und
das ist glaube ich auch der große
geschlossenheit da zu sagen es gibt
bestimmte prinzipien an denen werden wir
nicht rühren dessen um genommen was sie
gerade angesprochen haben natürlich der
versuch von macao und auch von von
scholz
punkte zu finden und auch mit den
amerikanern übrigens wo man mit putin
ins gespräch kommen kann
rüstungskontrolle die minsker abkommen
immer wieder genannt das ist natürlich
auch für russland ein ding mit dem sie
umgehen müssen weil da haben sie sich
immer wieder dazu verpflichtet dass man
gesagt hat okay die minsker abkommen
sind die
oder ist er der blueprint nachdem wir
die krise in der ost ukraine lösen
können und scholz hat deutlich gemacht
sowohl in moskau als auch in kiew dass
beide seiten etwas dafür tun müssen die
frage ist ob das interesse auf beiden
seiten oder vor allem auf der russischen
seite eben da ist bestimmte dinge zu tun
zum beispiel seine truppen aus der ost
ukraine abzuziehen ich frage nochmal wie
glaubwürdig der westen und wie
geschlossen er tatsächlich in der
gegenwärtigen situation ist in russland
spielt offenbar im moment die
öffentlichkeit des landes keine rolle
präsident putin kann offenbar frei
schalten und walten und wochentags weise
entscheiden welche strategie er
einschlägt wir haben gerade schon
darüber gesprochen
in frankreich gibt es eine wachsende
öffentliche debatte und einen wahltermin
im april in deutschland sagen sie herr
krüger ist im moment die regierung
geschlossener als sie vor einigen wochen
war herr kirschbaum was ist denn die ja
ich nenne es mal so was ist die
glaubwürdige drohung des westens ihr
sehen sie wladimir putin spielt und der
eindruck ist doch eher das im westen
alle sehr aufgeregt sind und nicht so
richtig klar ist wie man damit umgehen
kann ja ich meine in deutschland hat sie
haben es angesprochen die spd ist
wirklich nicht so klar gewesen
bundeskanzler shows hat vorher einige
wochen von einem wirtschaftlichen
projekten 2 genannt kämen kunde diese
leute was die äußere über wallstreet 2
ist amerikanische ohne wie schrecklich
das ist überhaupt nicht solidarisch und
das ist die bestehen ich weiß in europa
nicht nur in deutschland sondern in
europa ist man gegen diese neue stream
pipeline diesem stream pipeline ist war
gegen ukraine die ganze zeit gerüchte
das war ein für apple ukraine und die
ukraine scheint jeden tag darüber und
deutschland soll das 9 und wirtschaft
sich projekt und das sieht man wenigen
zwar bei beiden er wollte denn das
wollte stream 2 gar nicht in den mund
nehmen das ist das ist schon aufgefahren
in washington und deswegen ist natürlich
wunderbar jetzt seit ein paar wochen des
schutts und die deutsche regierung sogar
soldatisch ist aber es gibt trotzdem die
befürchtungen ja wenn es um sanktionen
geht vor allem wenn es nicht eine
richtige 1 zwei stunden
cyberangriff gibt was macht dein
deutschland wird deutschland auch diese
heute konnte sanktionen mitmachen oder
nicht und ich weiß nicht deutschland die
lieben frieden hier das ist wunderbar
dass die alles so frieden lieben aber es
gibt manchmal große börse aktuell ist in
der welt und ich bin gespannt ob
deutschland wirklich noch so solidarisch
bleibt was integrierten also ich finde
auch dass eine menge gegen nordwind 2
spricht vor allen dingen ökologische
einwände aber
der bundeskanzler hat einfach das
gemacht was alle anderen nato-partner
mit ausnahme der vereinigten staaten
auch gemacht haben niemand hat auf den
tisch gelegt welche sanktionen das
konkret sind und davon erhofft man sich
eine gewisse abschreckung wir können
gleich noch besprechen ob das abschreckt
was die europäer sich da vorgenommen
haben aber keiner hat das gemacht und
übrigens hat der vereinigte haben die
vereinigten staaten auch nicht auf den
tisch gelegt dass sie beispielsweise die
gaslieferung pardon die öllieferungen
aus russland kappen russland ist
inzwischen der drittgrößte öllieferant
für die usa geworden weil amerika kein
öl mehr aus venezuela nimmt da habe ich
auch nicht gehört dass man bereit ist
eventuell da ein ball kommt zu machen
und nicht mehr einzuführen und ich finde
das auch richtig übrigens weil wenn
jetzt nun jedes land sagt wir sind
bereit beispielsweise große
infrastrukturprojekte zu opfern dann
führt das nur zur verunsicherung im
westen aber dann wird putin das nicht
abschrecken wie glaubwürdig ist die
drohung
ich glaube die drohung mit sanktionen
ist sehr glaubwürdig ich glaube auch
dass es unterschiede oder abdichtungen
gibt weil der unterschied zwischen der
gasversorgung in deutschland ist dass
wir von russland abhängig sind während
die amerikaner relativ einfach ersatz
für das öl bekommen können das sieht
derzeit in russland kaufen deshalb
interessant billiger als in anderen
regionen aber das ist sozusagen keiner
keine abhängigkeit und die ist in
deutschland viel größer das hat
wirtschaftsminister habe vergangene
woche auch deutlich gemacht dass es
nicht sein könne dass die bundesrepublik
gar keine möglichkeit habe letztlich die
gasversorgung abzusichern ich glaube die
die
drohung ist mittlerweile sehr
glaubwürdig es gibt ab geschichte die
szenarien was man macht wenn
verschiedene dinge passieren dass man
die nicht öffentlich auf den tisch legt
ist klar weil sonst kann sich putin
sozusagen in dem menü aussuchen was
was er bereit ist in kauf zu nehmen oder
was nicht die frage ist glaube ich eher
die man sich stellen muss
wie funktioniert putins kalkül dass
putin nüchtern kalkuliert ist glaube ich
sicher
dass eine rationalität möglicherweise
eine andere ist als unsere ist ein
großes problem also wenn man sich
anschaut wie ihr wieder argumentiert zb
das historische argument in einem
aufsatz den im sommer veröffentlicht hat
dass die ukraine
und russland im prinzip ein start sind
beziehungsweise ein volk und prinzip der
der ukraine das recht auf eine
eigentliche staatlichkeit abspricht dann
spielen da vielleicht andere motive eine
rolle die er nicht unbedingt in dollar
oder rubel aufliegt sondern vielleicht
in
dimensionen seines historischen erbes
dass er hinterlassen ich lese gerade
jungen bei twitter welchen gewinn könnte
putin aus einer invasion erwarten seine
risiken sind klar was treibt ihn das ist
ihre antwort das ist ein historisches
verständnis von einem größeren russland
ja und ich meine es gibt dieses zitat
von ihnen der untergang der sowjetunion
ist die größte geopolitische katastrophe
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
das heißt nicht dass er die sowjetunion
wiederhaben will er hat auch gesagt wer
sich die sowjetunion zurückwünscht sei
dummen quasi aber was ja natürlich will
ist eine von russland dominierte
einflusssphäre und zu der gehören ganz
zentral laos und die ukraine die ukraine
ist dann auch wenn man in solchen
dimensionen eines groß russlands denkt
wirtschaftlich relativ wichtig sie ist
aus der geschichte wichtig es ist im
prinzip die die kernzelle
russischer moderner staatlichkeit und da
verschwimmen dann halt verschiedene
motive und da sind vielleicht dann auch
so forderungen nach sicherheitsgarantien
der nato oder des westens ein stück weit
auch nur vorgeschoben weil danke wir
sind noch bei der frage wie glaubwürdig
ist die abschreckung aber sie haben
haben einen wichtigen schritt gemacht
der glaube ich auch viele fragen hier im
netz beantwortet also welches motiv ist
es aber erst jetzt weil dabei auch die
abschreckung wurde mögliche abschreckung
der nato man darf auch nicht vergessen
vor paar jahren wird
2018 war das hat makro der motto den
hirntod
bescheinigt sich auf das amerikanische
hirn des bündnisses ja sicherlich aber
hat sich was geändert und welche rolle
könnte dann frankreich anstellen nun
übernehmen frankreich behauptet immer
wieder wir sind das einzige land in
europa in der union mit atommacht
schiff das im moment wohl kaum
aber gestern haben franzosen
behauptet also wir werden nicht
einmarschieren in die ukraine wir werden
nicht die die deutschen sowieso nicht
aus historischen grünen amerikaner haben
das auch schon in die vizepräsidentin
hat das auch schon angekündigt kommt
nicht in frage dass wir der truppen
hinschicken
ja mit ricoh sind da ja nur
wirtschaftlicher natur damit sind wir
bei einem punkt der mich im moment
eigentlich bewegt wenn ich bilder aus
kiew aus der ukraine sehe es gibt einen
spielball politisch ist das der staat
ukraine faktisch sind es die menschen
die in diesem land leben und wohnen
wolodimir ist lenski der präsident war
auch auf der sicherheitskonferenz in
münchen hat gestern gesprochen er war
ziemlich deutlich er hat gesagt wir
haben das recht einen wechsel von einer
peaceman politik zu einer politik zu
fordern die sicherheit und frieden
gewährleistet und dann sagte er
und es wird gesagt die tür steht offen
aber bis jetzt gibt es noch keine
möglichkeit dazu wie seien sie ehrlich
offene türen sind gut was wir brauchen
sind aber ehrliche antworten ja das
klingt nicht wie jemand der das gefühl
hat ich habe festen schutz und gute
unterstützung von schmidt ja die skepsis
ist berechtigt habe keine einzige nato
regierung gehört kann kein mitgliedsland
das sich jetzt dafür ausgesprochen hätte
dass die ukraine mitglied der nato wird
ganz einfach weil sie in allen
regionalen konflikt verwickelt ist
zynischer weise könnte man sagen putin
hat selbst dafür gesorgt indem er den
osten der ukraine im grunde in einem
kriegszustand versetzt hat und die nato
nimmt nie mitglieder auf die in einen
krieg oder in einen konflikt verwickelt
sind das ist so jetzt ist die nato
aufnahme das eine das andere ist eine
ganz konkrete bedrohungssituation
japanischen städte im land betrifft und
da fällt eben auch dass alle länder des
westens bei allen sanktionen die als
massiv so gravierend wie nie zuvor
beschrieben haben immer eine
militärische unterstützung
ausgeschlossen haben also kein land hat
gesagt wir schicken soldaten dorthin in
die ukraine um dort zu kämpfen
die sanktionen sind andere sind keine
militärischen im moment ja dass
irgendetwas anderes denkbar auch kamal
harris die us vizepräsidentin hat ja
gestern nochmal genau das betont dass er
gerade sagt ja ich meine keine will
hingehen um den einen krieg zu
unterstützen die die ganze nato
erweiterung war kontrovers auch in
amerika damals
ich weiß nicht ob ihnen hatte auf das
pech dass die dastehen würde ich saint
george bush hat den anfang der 90er auch
diese checks im camp speech gesagt wir
würden ukraine nicht unterstützen in
amerika weiß man dass ukraine wirklich
tsunamis anders das war eine große
provokation
62 mit der krise ist es zum diplomatie
job verhindert wurden das im krieg kommt
und kuba die wussten haben erkannt dass
kuba für die amerikaner sehr empfindlich
war und ich glaube die amerikaner
bestehen das ukraine wirklich etwas
heiliges ist russland und da darf man
hat ohnehin nicht viel anders denn herr
kirschbaum heisst das dass aus
amerikanischer sicht die ukraine als
russische einflusssphäre anerkannt ist
oder heißt das dass amerika zum
grundsatz der osze und der nato steht
dass ein land selbst entscheiden darf
welches bündnis ist man ja beides sowohl
ist auch aber es gibt kaum 19 jahren zu
sagen aber es passt ich habe kaum ein
amerikaner aus der ukrainische
abstimmungen
die sagen uns die nato gehören kein
amerikaner wird ein weltkrieg über
ukraine haben und ukraine eine antwort
haben will kann man sagen es wird in
unserem leben nicht passieren dass
ukraine nato kommt und hoffentlich kann
man wladimir putin überzeugen dass es so
ist und dann vielleicht gibt es keinen
sinnlosen krieg oder über diese
geschichte was anja marx und scholz
versucht im prinzip na also holz hat ja
bei seiner pressekonferenz im kreml
gesagt das wird nicht passieren sobald
wir noch so lange beide noch im amt sind
dann hat der putin angeguckt und gesagt
ich weiß ja nicht wie lange sie im amt
bleiben er und putin ist 70
das scheint nicht zu reichen bisher gut
ihm auch ganz deutlich gemacht aber
liegt dort die lösung geht es im kern
darum ob die ukraine formal das recht
behält nato mitglied zu werden wozu 30
länder ja sagen müssen den arm heben
müssen also in biblis die sich das 31 ja
gut aber geht es darum russland
irgendeine sicherheit zu geben über die
köpfe der ukraine in der k frage
ja welche sicherheit mal wahrscheinlich
erwartet zielinski darauf diese
beistandsverpflichtung zu bekommt jeder
nicht bekommt weil er noch nicht in der
nato ist und und jetzt auch nicht
bekommen wird das
land rechnet damit dass steht also dass
der militärische oder und
aber auch wenn andererseits bei dieser
ganzen krise die westlichen also die die
europäer sagen zu der ukraine wir werden
euch unterstützen meinetwegen auch mit
schutzhelmen aber ich weiß nicht ob es
ein gutes beispiel war das alles noch
nicht mithalten so lange aber
was erwarten auch die ukraine die
ukraine erwarten mehr schutzhelme die
warten mehr als eine eine schöne rede
irgendwo vor allem parlament die wollen
auch eine tatkräftige unterstützung und
die diese unterstützung muss ja
definiert werden
ist es ein zeichen
ein gutes zeichen dafür dass der heutige
generalsekretär der nato
bald durch einen nachfolger haben wird
vielleicht war das wäre das der moment
um zu sagen
stichwort hirntod die nato zu
reformieren so in die richtung dass man
eben
in der zwickmühle ist leuten oder
ländern was
zu versprechen was man nicht halten kann
und das kann man nicht im moment
erhalten
weil weil wie sie sagten 30 länder also
einstimmig mit 30 ländern beschlossen
werden sascha krieger ist eine neutrale
ukraine die lösung ja ich denke in diese
richtung sollte man sollte man denken
denn eine militärische lösung kann es
nicht geben also alle spontanen
waffenlieferungen ändern nichts daran
dass die russische armee um ein
vielfaches überlegen ist dass das kann
man überhaupt nicht ausgedacht also
diese richtung machen wir gar nicht zu
denken da da liegt keine lösung die
lösung könnte darin liegen dass
diplomaten jetzt das tun was sie ja wenn
sie erfolgreich sind oft tun sich in die
lage des anderen versetzen nicht seine
position annehmen aber die dinge mal aus
einer brille aus putins brille zu
betrachten und dann sieht es einfach
wirklich ja so aus dass immer mehr
länder sich für freiheit und rechtsstaat
entschieden haben und dass durch an
bündnisse mich die nato absichern lassen
und er sieht jetzt aus moskau nur noch
die ukraine und weißrussland dazwischen
dann kommt schon der rechtsstaat das ist
für ihn offensichtlich eine bedrohung
und dann wäre ja tatsächlich eine eine
überlegung zu gucken ob man so eine
finnland ii sierung das ist ja so ein
neutraler staat wobei finnland jetzt
selber auch die wada die abstatt
nato-mitglieds wir hatten also muss man
sich ein anderes wort überlegen aber so
einen einen neutralen stark der
sicherheitsgarantien für die ukraine
beinhaltet natürlich darf dieses land
nicht verraten werden der auf der
anderen seite putin den wind auf denen
aus den segeln nimmt wenn er so tut als
sei da nun der westen der russland
bedroht mit dieser mitgliedschaft das
ist der balance akt den jetzt diplomaten
ja gehen müssen eine lösung finden
dann hat man ja ich glaube der finnische
präsident hat ja gestern auch darauf
hingewiesen dass die finalisierung jetzt
ja auch nichts ist was ich dich finden
irgendwie aus freien stücken
herbeigewünscht haben sondern
die erzwungen wurde durch eine massive
militärische intervention damals der
sowjetunion
auf finnischem boden also so zu tun als
ob das jetzt irgendwie
ja etwas völlig
problemlos wäre oder oder wünschenswert
dass da wäre ich sehr vorsichtig also
das ist funktioniert hat ja erst mal
muss man glaube ich gucken ob die
ukraine dazu bereit sind auch ob sie
bereit sind zum beispiel ihre
beitrittsperspektive zur nato aufzugeben
letztlich in der ukraine jetzt sagen
das wird nix und ihr erklärt euch jetzt
bitte mal neutral hat ja putin das
erreicht was er will nämlich die
souveränität der ukraine einzuschränken
und die ukraine zurückzuholen in den
russischen einfluss kosmos wo im prinzip
moskau bestimmt was in kiew gemacht
werden kann und was nicht so und wie
empfindlich gerade finnland und schweden
darauf reagieren die jetzt neutral sind
haben in den letzten tagen gesehen die
sind alle zur nato gekommen nach brüssel
und haben gesagt ja also wir bestehen
darauf als neutrale staaten dass das
prinzip der freien bündnisfall
erhalten bleibt und wir bestehen auch
darauf dass die nato ihre politik der
offenen tür beibehält
das zeigt ja nur es fühlen sich auch
andere als die ukraine von dem was putin
dort tut bedroht weil es nicht nur darum
geht ob die ukraine jetzt eine konkrete
perspektive hat sondern weil es darum
geht ob die ordnung auf die man sich
geeinigt hat und zwar mit russland nach
dem ende des kalten krieges in europa
über den haufen geworfen geworfen wird
oder nicht und dazu gehört die
territoriale integrität von staaten die
achtung von grenzen und dass diese nicht
mit gewalt verschoben werden und dazu
gehört auch das prinzip der freien
bündnis war
gleiche frage an sie also ist die
neutrale ukraine die lösung ich lese
hier in den tritt und & poor's immer
wieder warum muss die nato bis an die
russische grenze warum muss russland
eingekreist werden das ist ja das was
platini putin auch sagt und dann stellt
sich sofort die frage also mal
angenommen die ukraine würde das spiel
mitmachen und sie würde finnland visiert
ist dann ende der fahnenstange oder was
ist dann mit dem ball gekommen was ist
mit schweden und finnland also ist es
die löhne oder wäre es nur sag mal
gestern also nicht dass die who sind da
sagt optieren würde das ukraine
deutscher bleibt das ganze fing 20 14 an
mit der eu assoziierungsabkommen
zu rufen die spannung an das war nicht
unbedingt die nato-erweiterung dann ja
ich weiß in deutschland vor allem in
ostdeutschland ehemalige ddr vier
sympathie für russlands meinung nato
erweitert sich wird eingekreist aber den
90er jahren weil er ganz andere
situation es gab sogar gespräche von j
das puder dass du so ein mitglied von
nato werden wo das war eine ganz andere
moment und ja heute kann man sehen
vielleicht war es ein fehler eine
historische fähre nato-erweiterung polen
und so weiter und so fort vielleicht hat
der nato was andere sagen aber wir haben
den salat jetzt vorhaben nato ukraine
werden auf jeden fall nie
nato-mitglieder ich will dass wieder
leben aber wenn das wussten nicht reicht
dann haben wir ein problem und das ist
wirklich die stunde der diplomatie ich
liebe diese helmut schmidt zitat
angeblich besser 1000 stunden zu
verhandeln aus einer minute zu schießen
und hoffentlich werden diplomaten jetzt
die stunde der stunde der diplomatie
seien aber von einer nato einkreisung
von muss man ich finde das nicht das was
es ist nato ist wirklich ein
verteidigungsbündnis sind es war bis
2014 keine nato soldaten in osteuropa
das war eine freiwillige bunde ist und
so sollte es bleiben also ich halte fest
es gibt unterschiedliche einschätzungen
am tisch ob es die lösung wäre die
ukraine zu bewegen
auf ihr recht sage ich mal der bündnis
findung zu verzichten ich würde gerne
zum schluss ein kleines stück heraus
zoomen aus dem bild wir haben jetzt 2022
werden 2014 eine ähnliche situation
in russland gibt es seit 20 jahren einen
präsidenten
der offenbar vom besten kollektiv nicht
richtig eingeschätzt worden ist sonst
könnten wir außenpolitisch nicht in der
situation sein dass wir
in europa kollektiv angst vor einem
neuen krieg haben sie atmen tief
ja ich weiß nicht ob man putin falsch
eingeschätzt hat man hat vielleicht
seine entschlossenheit falsch
eingeschätzt und hat auch über vieles
hinweg gesehen das sind ja auch dinge
die offen auf dem tisch liegen also
putin betreibt seit 20 jahren
einen anbau und eine modernisierung des
staates das geht auf der einen seite
intern mit der verstärkten repressionen
also hat im prinzip jede demokratische
opposition und jetzt auch die letzte
menschenrechtsgruppe dort noch
ausgeschaltet das heißt er hat intern
seine macht absolut gefestigten er hat
zugleich seine streitkräfte modernisiert
auf eine art und weise
die dieser kontinent in den letzten also
wie seit das ende seit ende des kalten
krieges nicht gesehen hat sie sind in
syrien im einsatz gewesen das gesamte
offizierskorps hat in syrien
kampferfahrungen gesammelt die frage ist
ja ist bei vieles davon kann nicht das
ziel westlicher politik gewesen sein
also meine frage ist raus ja aus fehlern
lernen und lernen hier posieren also ich
fürchte putin beobachtet genau so wie
wir das alles gesagt wird in westeuropa
und der weiß ganz genau was ihn erwartet
wenn er zu weit geht und ich glaube der
wird auch selber die grenze
bestimmen bis
bis er auf wird vielleicht erfahren wir
dann in den nächsten tagen das plötzlich
eincremen 02 passiert dass plötzlich die
russen da sind bis kiew keine waffen
keine tote kein anschläge kennen gar
nichts und die die europäer gucken zu
und wenn es auch keine kein keine große
krise gibt 1 in der ukraine wende man
weiß ja auch nicht wie die ukrainer
selber darauf reagieren wenn es auch
keine schüsse gibt wenn
dann nach wir ganz schlechte karten mit
drohungen mit sanktionen und
große probleme auch mehr seit der
unterstützung eine frage gibt diese
versprochen haben eine historische
lektion für brüssel verschenken für
berlin also ich glaube es ist schon
richtig dass wenige das vorausgesagt
haben dass da wirklich ein diktator
krieg macht mitten in europa über alle
regeln des völkerrechts sich hinweg satz
stattdessen aus dem 17ten jahrhundert
ideen von völkischer einheit aus der
mottenkiste hervorgeholt das hätten wir
vor einem jahr noch als lächerlich
empfunden und das konnte das hat niemand
vorausgesehen
der zweite teil der frage ist ja hat der
westen da was falsch gemacht es gab ja
immer einige länder deutschland
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel war da
führen aber auch der französische
staatspräsident ma cordi immer in der eu
dafür plädiert haben lasst uns die
gesprächskanäle aufrechterhalten lasst
uns verhandeln ich erinnere mich an den
letzten gipfel von frau merkel hat sie
versucht putin zu einem gipfel
einzuladen und sie ist komplett
gescheitert damit alle anderen eu länder
mit ausnahme frankreichs haben das
verhindert die wollten nicht mit putin
sprechen ich finde jetzt im nachhinein
muss es sagt muss man sagen ist doch gut
dass einige länder den gesprächskanal
nicht geschlossen haben sonst hätten wir
jetzt überhaupt nicht die chance zu
verhandeln hat chris brown gehört ja
große fülle war von barack obama der
sagte was seines neuen regeln macht das
ist auch vielleicht ein wechsel der
ganzen probleme diese fehlende respekt
gegenüber moskau gegen russland das haus
dann hoffentlich die usa und viele
andere länder gelernt dass russland ist
ein weltmarkt und und braucht
respekt behandelt zu werden das könnte
vielleicht eine lösung hier sein wenn
vielleicht doch das gefühl bekommen als
bekommt alle kommen zu ihm
alles um den krieg zu werden weiß ich
nicht aber das war ein großer fehler von
barack obama will santos regionalmarkt
abzukanzeln
ist tut ihm sicher dass die russische
bevölkerung auch dahinter steht also das
muss ja nicht
er muss sich ja nicht wiederwählen
lassen
also ich glaube die lehre ist dass man
jetzt bei den prozessen hier ohnehin
anstehenden in der nato und in der eu
sich sehr gut überlegen müssen wie man
mit dieser situation umgeht und was das
längerfristigen konsequenzen bedeutet
kannst scholz hat in moskau gesagt er
gehöre einer generation an die sich
nicht mehr habe vorstellen können dass
es krieg in europa gibt putin hat jetzt
klar gemacht dass militärische macht
wieder ein mittel ist und politik in
europa zu machen in der internationalen
arena und damit wird man sich
auseinandersetzen müssen und deshalb
glaube ich sehr weitreichende
konsequenzen weil wir einfach 20 30
jahre lang nach dem fall der mauer davon
ausgegangen sind dass diese regeln die
wir uns gemeinsam gegeben haben mit
einem russland das damals natürlich
völlig anders da stand schwach war nach
dem zerfall der sowjetunion
dass wir da jetzt nach anderen
spielregeln wieder spielen bedanke mich
sehr herzlich wir können nicht klären ob
die eskalation zwangsläufig auf einen
größeren militärischen konflikt
hinausläuft oder im moment noch ein
kontrolliertes schachspiel ist wir
konnten nicht klären ob ein anderer
status der ukraine der beitrag zur
lösung dieses konflikts ist wir haben
aber erklären können dass das ergebnis
von heute
langjährige außenpolitische und
diplomatische nachdenklichkeit auslösen
sollte bedanke mich sehr herzlich hier
in der ard jetzt aus peking die
schlussfeier der olympischen spiele und
im radio und bei phoenix presseclub
nachgefragt danke tschüss und lassen sie
und willkommen zurück presseclub
nachgefragt im radio bei wdr 5 im
fernsehen bei phoenix sie haben das wort
und wir starten in berlin mit claudia
bis koubsky willkommen in der sendung
dank für den anruf
[Musik]
abhängig
gemacht hat und auch die kann ich
endlich
danke für die frage ich glaube das geht
vielen durch den kopf herr krüger
sendern liegt ja das ist natürlich die
frage weil in dieser ganzen kalkulation
muss man natürlich mit auf dem zettel
haben dass russland ja auf sanktionen
auch wahrscheinlich reagieren würden
aber ich glaube diese überlegungen hat
man sich in brüssel gemacht die
kommissionspräsident in unserer von
allein hat gestern auf der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz versichert dass man
jetzt so weit sei dass die gasversorgung
europas auch gesichert wäre ist in den
sommer wenn russland seine lieferungen
komplett unterbrechen würde
russland das tun würde da wäre ich mir
gar nicht mal so sicher weil das sind
natürlich letztlich die gas und öl ein
großteil der staatsanleihen in russland
also dann man glaube ich egal wie diese
eskalation abläuft trotzdem ein
grundlegendes interesse dass man da
nicht alle brücken abbricht und gewisse
wirtschaftskontakte weitergehen dies ja
auch schon zu zeiten also wie jetzt dann
muss ich eben hat aber ja es ist
natürlich so dass wir nicht nur gas aus
russland beziehen sondern auch bestimmte
metalle zum beispiel und das s rück
wirkungen haben kann
auf europa das ist einkalkuliert
und deswegen glaube ich schon dass diese
drohung relativ glaubwürdig ist ja okay
frage ist ob wir können es auch nur
vermuten aber
das gewicht dessen für die
bundesrepublik ist glaube ich deutlich
danke und grosz nach berlin
wir gehen nach holtrop bei aurich in
ostfriesland michael taddicken es in der
leitung bekommen
vielen dank in die runde
ich beschäftige mich beschäftigt wie
groß der schaden der deutschen haltung
in
europa ist
besonders in osteuropa vertrauen
zerstört weil das weil damals die
symbolische geste mit dem 5000 helm ist
ja nicht wahr ja nicht wirklich
überzeugend und ich denke schon dass es
vertrauen für eine weitere
außenpolitische sicherheitspolitische
integration doch irgendwo beschädigt
wurde und mich heute besonders
interessieren wie kann deutschland
diesen schaden wieder reparieren
zumindest minimieren also der
bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat mehrmals
darauf hingewiesen und und ich denke
auch zu recht dass kein land die ukraine
mit so viel geld unterstützt hat in den
vergangenen jahren wie deutschland und
ein zweiter punkt den ich auch wichtig
finde ist dass ein land das für alle
ewigkeit verantwortlich sein wird für
mehr als 20 millionen tote in der
ukraine und in russland hat natürlich
eine ganz hohe hemmschwelle nun waffen
in ausgerechnet dieser region zu liefern
zumal alle militärexperten im
nato-hauptquartier aber auch in den
einzelnen mitgliedsländern sagen diese
waffenlieferungen die jetzt kommen die
tragen überhaupt die tragen nichts dazu
bei dass die gerade die lufthoheit der
einmal der der russen enorm ist und dazu
führen wird dass in zwei drei tagen das
land erobert sein wird die abschreckung
die die militärs ersehen und da spielen
die waffenlieferungen jüngster
derzeit gar keine rolle das ist er so
einen guerillakampf ein partisanenkampf
der sind haben die polen die sowjet
bestände der ukrainischen armee
modernisiert und da sitzt man jetzt so
ein bisschen hoffnung darauf dass das
putin vielleicht abschreckt eine
ähnliche situation wie in tschetschenien
herzustellen mit einem furchtbaren
bürgerkrieg der über jahre einen ganz
großen schaden anrichtet aber ich kann
nicht sehen dass deutschland da in der
kritik steht euro überkauft deutschland
waffen katar an gibt den saudi arabien
das und
damit vermutlich nicht mehr antworten
verteidigen der versuch einer replik
danke dass sie dabei sind bruce in den
norden und dann würde ich sagen nochmal
berlin frank derart guten tag
guten tag gruß in meine alte heimat
richtung köln
ich hab ne frage und zwar durch der
immer gerätselt was will der putin
eigentlich und da kommt die darüber ob
diese rationaler spieler und was halten
sie von folgendem vorschlag putin
bilderwelt vorführen wie sich das
anfühlt wenn ein land gelingt wird von
gegnerischen block und gleichzeitig die
umzingelten truppen sagen
das macht russland gerade mit der
ukraine und vorher hatte die nato mit
russland gemacht und eigentlich
vorbilder polnischen volk
gottes willen sie müssen auch sicher
kein verdacht unterziehen auch wenn sie
es wären dürften sie sagen aber danke
also erhält letztlich den spiegel vor
sagen ja sparen was halten sie von der
ja diese nato und russland lehne ich
aber es gibt keine um sicherung von
usern es gibt keine aggressive
offensiver waffen an der grenze zu
russland das ist quatsch und wenn man
das denkt das ist kann man das mit mir
gar nichts diskutieren weil das ist
gegen die fakten nato wie gesagt ist ein
freiwilliger bundes von partner die
zusammen kämpfen vertigo 5 wenn es ein
angriff geber nato ist kein angriff
block und das ist eine ganz falsche
behauptung von vier in deutschland ich
immer wieder höher also ich würde ihn
auf der würde ihn persönlich sofort
zustimmen aber
vielleicht so habe ich herrn geraths
verstanden ist das genau das problem
also dass wir uns dessen so sicher sind
weil wir eben dieses verständnis von
nato haben aber ausblenden wie das
empfinden in moskau als in zürich
wollen sozusagen auch im gespräch mit
marko hat das so putin selber dementiert
wurde im juli letzten jahres hat putin
ein beitrag selber geschrieben der ist
an sämtliche soldaten so russische
seiten geschickt worden und auch in den
botschaften russlands im westen
veröffentlicht worden also in paris auf
französisch die sehen konnte ich also
aufmerksam lesen und
dementiert einfach diese diesen
standpunkt dass die nato nur defensive
hat
defensive aktivität hat belgrad genannt
hat er einige beispiele genannt
afghanistan genannt und so gut dass eine
frage der interpretation nachher und das
ist die russische interpretation aber
damit arbeitet er und hat auch
wahrscheinlich in europa
genug leute die richtig zugehört haben
und vielleicht ihm recht gegeben haben
das ist genau ich würde gerne ich würde
gerne mehr nachgefragt und gern viele in
der leitung an sofern wir lassen es
einfach stehen es spannend zu
diskutieren herr gerat und
wahrscheinlich rührt das genau an den
kern ist das jetzt nur taktik oder
wirkliches empfinden von bedrohungen
bedanke mich grosz nach berlin
und geh nach dorsten klaus reiprich
guten tag nach dessen
ich habe mal eine frage warum verhandelt
man nicht mit der ukraine das die erst
mal sagen sie bleiben neutral 20 jahre
bis man die spannung raus rad und wir
geben ihnen als europäer dafür dass sie
in europa aufgrund werden können und
auch alle wirtschaftliche vorteile haben
das war meine frage und eine good luck
dazu habe ich gerade gehört die nato hat
ohne grund jugoslawien angegriffen also
ist dieser angriff nato die die autobahn
nicht bedroht schönen tag noch ja danke
herr reiprich für den einwurf und ich
spitze ihre frage mal so zu die ukraine
wirtschaftlich in den westen integrieren
aber militärisch neutral wurde die
ukraine muss antworten das ist ja eine
frage die nato ja sogar das empfehlen
europa kann das auch vielleicht begrüßen
aber die entscheidung muss die ukraine
treffen um so viel ich gehört habe ist
das nicht der standpunkt der ukraine und
herstellung hat sondern auch schon
richtig gesagt es ist nicht so dass
putin bereit wäre eine wirtschaftliche
integration der ukraine in die eu ohne
weiteres zu akzeptieren
birgit schneider in bonn ist die nächste
hallo liebe freischneider gekommen
und hat uns auf hochkultur weise eine
rede gehalten in deutsch das muss man
sich bedenken und er hat uns
vorgeschlagen eine neue sicherheits
konstruktion für europa zu finden seit
mehr als 20 jahren haben wir dieses
ereignis völlig übergang ich nehme an
dass es gar nicht wahrnehmen dann hätten
wir heute nämlich nicht das verbrannte
brot aus dem ofen qualmen als in der
ukraine heute
erinnern sie noch was der kerngedanke
war also was wollte er was war sein
lösungsvorschlag der nicht wahr
danke für die
am ryck erinnerung also war das eine
odere die verpasste chance haben ja eben
auch schon mal darüber gesprochen dass
man putin hat vor 15 jahren schon in
münchen
klargemacht was er eigentlich will
und das ist ja einfach so
nicht war es sicherlich wahrgenommen
worden aber nicht so respektiert dass
man daraus auch eine neue politik
definieren wollte ich finde diese
erinnerung an 2001 auch wirklich sehr
schön das war eine andere zeit da hatten
wir eine große hoffnungen und in der tat
wurde da auch diskutiert ob nicht
russland eines tages mit mitglied der
nato werden könnte das stimmt danach ist
viel passiert übrigens in russland
danach gab es fürchterliche kriege
gegeben die putin geführt hat er hat
alles zerstört
im land was es damals an freier presse
ja gab das ist das ist lange her aber
das gab es und er hat vor allen dingen
auch jede form von opposition zerstört
jeder der groß wurde neben ihnen musste
mit mit einem mordanschlag rechnen und
die letzte institution der
zivilgesellschaft memorial das wurde
vorhin schon erwähnt ist nun auch
verboten also die frage ist ja wäre das
alles anders gekommen wenn man damals
alles offen angegangen das wissen wir
nicht
wir lassen stehen so schneider sie
merken es ist ja ich sag mal auch teil
der großen ratlosigkeit ob man die
situation wie man sie hätte vermeiden
können aber auch dass ein wertvoller
hinweis danke und groß nach bonn und
dann sind wir in bielefeld bei thomas
wagner
guten plug in die wunde
ich habe eine frage an ihren tisch raum
und zwar einen anschein nach könnte die
kriegsgefahr ja eigentlich gewarnt
werden wenn die nato offiziell darauf
verzichten würde sich in irgendeiner
weise weiteren russland zu erweitern
meine frage warum ist diese option so
stark ausgeschlossen der nato ist ja
eigentlich nicht immer weiter gewachsen
sondern die sicherheit der
mitgliedstaaten zu gewähren die der
aufgabe wäre weiterhin
besser entwickelt hätten speziell
vergleich der usa sprechen gegen ein
solches
die regierung stichwort dabei vielleicht
öffentlichen der störung in john mccain
der einige ambitionen in der richtung
bewegt hat die ukraine
zu holen danke herr wagner frage klar
und angekommen so weit ich weiß die
washingtoner vertrag der nato
gründungsvertrag steht alle europäische
länder die das einkommen wohnen können
reinkommen und das musste man das alles
enden ich glaube das ist nicht so
einfach das nato einfach sagt nee die
kommunalwahlen das hätte ja auch zur
folge dass man nicht einfach immer mehr
das selbstbestimmungsrecht der völker
nicht mehr anerkennt denn das ist ja
festgelegt jedes land muss das recht
haben sich sein bündnis selber
auszusuchen und darüber kann sich die
nato als institutionen denke ich recht
ja gut aber ich sage mal es geht ja auch
um das selbstbestimmungsrecht der
jetzigen mitglieder also die könnten ja
durchaus recht sagen wir haben eine
vereinbarung aber wir schließen unseren
klub jetzt ist doch hin beschlossen das
einstimmig zu entscheiden also bei 30
ländern gibt es auch die möglichkeit
dass so ein paar doch mit nicht
mitmachen aber ich habe natürlich die
frage spannend und ich formuliere sind
noch mal anders also wir alle wissen
dass es in unserer lebzeit nicht
passieren wird das 30 nato-mitglieder
irgendwo östlich noch dafür sind ein
weiteres mitglied aufzunehmen
es ist also ein bisschen wie beim trotz
kind das man sagt nein wir halten die
möglichkeit offen ich glaube frau
schmidt hat das ja schon gesagt also es
geht um prinzipien auf die man sich
geeinigt hat auf die man sich auch mit
russland geeinigt hat jetzt kann man
sein okay man
handhabt das pragmatisch dann muss es
aber auch von beiden seiten pragmatisch
gehandhabt werden der bundeskanzler hat
das ja gesagt das steht nicht zur
debatte es liegt nicht an es ist kein
aktueller
kriegsgrund oder man kann daraus keinen
aktuellen kriegsgrund machen da stehen
zwei dinge dahinter einmal der zweifel
das ist das tatsächlich ist um was es
geht da hat sich auch die allergrößten
zweifel und das andere ist okay wenn wir
sozusagen
argumentieren mit dem was tatsächlich
auf dem tisch liegt dann steht es eben
nicht zur debatte aber putin hat auch
ganz klar auf dieser pressekonferenz im
kreml zu verstehen gegeben dass ihnen
das eben nicht ausreicht und dann geht
es wahrscheinlich darum vielleicht für
ihn doch die brechstange an die nato zu
setzen und wenn man jetzt die russischen
vorschläge liest die sie der nato
unterbreitet haben geht das ja weiter
rückzug der nato truppen auf den stand
von 97 als die nato grund akte
geschlossen das ist natürlich das
typische prinzip der eskalation dass wir
gerade haben es wird immer noch etwas
draufgelegt danke herr wagner groß nach
bielefeld und weil er einmal in der
gegend sind stelle ich ganz zum schluss
noch mit der bitte um einen ein antwort
satz von jemandem der sich zutraut die
frage von volker grenz aus lemgo kann ex
kanzler schröder mit seinem engen draht
zu putin vermitteln
klar warum nicht lohnt sich schon krank
und ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen
sonntag und hoffe dass nicht nur die
meteorologischen stimmen abziehen danke
gruß aus köln lassen sie es gut gehen
[Musik]
phoenix vor ort
herzlich willkommen an diesem
sonntagnachmittag wie geht es weiter im
russland konflikt und was passiert
aktuell in der ost ukraine damit
beschäftigt